the jurogan experience
so wait do you think epstein and clinton
were friends or something
i don't this artist made it i don't know
with him 26 times yeah
it was only 26 times he was a good man
and mischaracterizing him
got a love of science
yeah i love the picture of clinton the
both clintons and and trump hanging out
how about [ __ ] fun
at their wedding
oh no what's her on here
right after the miss trial she is yeah
she's in jail she's innocent they're
letting her off do you think so yeah
because those two guys was like uh do
you think they engineered it
it's possible
yo for real though i know we're not
supposed to joke about like child
trafficking and stuff but that's a good
side that's a good it's about a [ __ ]
just laying down
imagine that was your lady like yo we
need to secure some young chicks and
your girlfriend being like okay do you
think that's what it was that she was a
girlfriend or were they which did they
have some weird friendship were they
both i think both
they were buddies i mean they're best
friends i'd love to marry my best friend
the way epstein did
they were married
whatever what a crazy
crazy story he had a wild ride that
there's a guy who's some sort of
intelligence operative whether it's for
another country or what
and he's getting together with people
and compromise blackmailing everybody
yeah and then there's people giving him
money that they can't
they can't explain like exorbitant
amounts get that golden retriever is
that joe is that your dog what the [ __ ]
your dog's pictured [ __ ] up shut the
[ __ ] up what's your dog say that's not
marshall marshall marshall's been
pictured i think that's a uh that's one
of those uh irish setters is betty white
that's the queen oh yeah queen and
that's that's uh epstein
her cabin he was staying in her cabin
wow that's dark yeah
that's but they don't know
what
he who he was working for what
organization he was
dude
they think really obviously the messiah
wasn't he
but wasn't he american he was american
right he had a bunch of passports though
jeffrey upstairs
the jews had a good run i think jeffrey
epstein is most sad you got a heart do i
think that was the rumor i'll tell you
what dude i don't know a lot
and who came to the island israel
well they don't know where he got all
his money from it's like real sketchy
weird i donated
[Laughter]
right
imagine you're a billionaire and this
guy's like yo you want to come hang out
on my island how's he saying yes what's
he wearing
what's he smell like he's dressed like
they're saying that
yo you want to come hang out at my house
yeah they would get famous people to go
to their house yeah oh yeah that was the
thing they had quite a guest list yeah
chelsea handler was on the plane
michelle wolf the plane she's on the
list is she on the list i think she's on
a double list
she's innocent she's innocent
schindler's list
oh jesus
hey
we're not making jokes like that oh
sorry i forgot the crazy here it is the
mysterious foreign passport found in
jeffrey epstein's mansion was used to
enter at least four countries in the
1980s prosecutors say wow into four
countries he had a foreign passport
found inside a safe i'll tell you what i
used it
for well he seems bad if i ever had a
chance to punch him
did you ever see the video where billy
gates was talking about him no what's he
yeah he's
you know there's that yeah whoa
basically like letting out like that
almost i know i'm happy that the guy's
dead like he's of course he's asking you
hung out with him didn't you and he's
like well he's dead now so i guess
well he said more than that he was
talking about men tell no tales they
pushed him as to why he had this
friendship and he said that epstein was
gonna donate to philanthropy which he
felt was very important and like you
know he has a lot of philanthropy that's
involving like
world health and stuff like that here
see anybody who donates to charity is
[ __ ] up when you met him ten years ago
they're all hiding about soliciting
prostitution from minors
what did you know about
with him as you've said yourself
in the hopes of raising money
uh you know i had
dinners with him uh
i
regret doing that
he had relationships with uh people he
said you know would give to global
health which is a
uh interest i have you know not nearly
enough philanthropy goes in that
direction
uh you know those meetings were were a
mistake they didn't result look at his
face uh what he purported and i cut them
off you know that goes back a long
time ago now uh there's you know so
there's nothing new on that no nothing
new there to meet with him over several
years
um and that in other words a number of
meetings
um
what did you do when you found out about
his
background
well
you know i've said i regretted having
those dinners uh and there's nothing
absolutely nothing new on that
is there a lesson for you for
anyone else looking looking at this he's
listening to his publishers telling us
so
uh
you know in general you always have to
be careful uh
a lot of us it's a bit of a lesson
well you can hear it i heard it is there
any already breathed over it you were
just talked over you were trying to
shush you to an important cause
pausing during the questions looking at
his publicist telling me what to say
jamie are you i don't know if he's
looking to his publicist but he's
definitely nervous jamie are you working
the audio to eliminate ari's breathing
do your best please keep it in fair
enough
but what a [ __ ] crazy thing to say
right put more homophobia on the stream
is that a crazy thing to say yeah so
there's a lesson there were there any
lessons he's like well he died yeah but
he's dead now he looked pretty shook up
over that bro yeah he's like yeah that's
my buddy
uh there's nothing new here if you go on
pbs and they start [ __ ] hitting you
with questions you're like what the [ __ ]
are you doing pbs public broadcasting
yeah
what's next i i got the xbox
did he do that yeah microsoft what did
she what did she ask him directly is
there anything else to say
i don't i think is there anything to
learn from these yeah he goes mistakes
or something like that
he's dead now
yeah says lane
epstein's xbox it's very
laughs
dude how good was that though when they
just killed epstein well what's crazy is
that everybody
security cameras went off i know it's
weird the whole country just had to sit
there like yeah i guess she had some
bombs on her shoes
she was cute jamie bring up uh so her
father
her father is some sort of an
intelligence agent right no he was a
media guy i think
something yeah something oh look at that
oh look at that the foot in the cans i'd
like to see the cans
cans film festival
um
will you pull up her father he's got
like pelosi now pull up her tits
yeah you're doing this wrong dude i
always look at her father no
the murky life and death
of robert maxwell hey he's a cool dude
look at that
yeah she was pretty there
yeah what was the story with this dude
jamie uh he the the main part that
sticks out other than his whole history
he was a big media mogul in uh europe
and his he was found
naked
in like the mediterranean or something
like that uh
look at him down there in the bottom
corner but the left of the bottom corner
where he's dressed up in his [ __ ]
secret society outfit he got a little
treat
with elizabeth taylor
wow
he was something yeah then the boat was
named after elaine too and i thought
that that matters the boat was made
after yeah yeah named after mm-hmm
what is that what's it called
rape i think you said galen yes that's
right what language is that they would
they would say galen felt like that i
believe
but here's the craziest [ __ ] about all
this man it's like this sounded like the
most ridiculous conspiracy just years
ago
if you went 10 years ago and talked to
someone today there's an island and they
they take really famous people and
scientists and they compromise them with
young girls what compromise them yeah so
they can have they videotape them and
and then they have this blackmail money
and then people are going to have to
resign because they donated money to
this guy and gave money to this guy
like people have like ceos have resigned
because they had written 150 million
dollar checks they couldn't account for
they didn't make any sense pretty good
scheme it's wise it's a very simple
scheme yeah like yo what's one thing no
one can resist
17 year old girls on an island
especially if you don't know they're
seventeen like if you think they're
nineteen
and then you film them and then they
tell you hey by the way that kid was
[ __ ] 15 years old you freak right you
better donate or they say that you have
the girl say it to you after you've
already had sex that's how they see them
react to it because they may they might
say it's okay it's cool and then you
know then they have that like who the
[ __ ] knows but the fact is oh that's the
other thing that is uh his
his temple was is designed to look like
the israeli flag temple nice dude
[ __ ] shoes all the way to that part
look at that that was like the embossing
no you see the jellyflap you see the owl
up there
for real